This one is a Akami
You don't need teeth to eat that
Tokyo Japan, there's no question. It's one of the world's top food cities today
I'm taking you on an exclusive sushi journey where we're going to see the entire sushi cycle from the fish auction
- the tuna slicing
- eating sushi right out of the fingers of the chef
Get ready to witness the art of the best sushi in the world
Hey everyone, I hope you're having an amazing day, it's mark Wiens
I'm in Tokyo Japan, and I'm here with the hungry tourists on his best of Tokyo food tour. It's exactly 4:30 a.m.
Right now we're gonna go catch a taxi to the market
That was a mess
good morning, David morning, and we are
On our way to go find chef hero Sato who is a master Xu sushi chef
And he's going to be taking us into the market every sushi chef in Tokyo
visits this market every morning
to get fresh fish for the day
We met up with Chef Hiro Sato and we're now just walking into the inner market of sketchy market this is
This is where you want to be careful not to get hit by by carts or our trolleys
Oh, man, this is this is awesome. I'm starting to get really really excited
At this time you can see all of the vendors, they're setting up, there is a fresh catch of the day as in and
Every sushi chef in Tokyo has their own
vendor that they go back to over and over again, and so chef knows exactly where we're going oh
wow
Before we do anything though proper footwear is a must
Oh
and a cap
Okay, oh yeah, I'm fully totally ready for the fish market so nice outfit. Yeah
This is seriously a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity. Not only are we at an?
exclusive area
for buyers only at Tsukiji market
That is in the fest and the boots
And by the way Iggy fish market is the this is the biggest fish seafood market in the entire world, it's gigantic
All of a sudden we're entering into the Arctic chill room. Oh, this is the tuna room?
Oh, this is where the auction is happening
This is by far the most
Gigantic tuna I have ever seen in my entire life
oh
It's massive
If you ever eat the best sushi the best quality tuna it all passes through this market and this auction
We got bleacher seats I think that Bell signifies the start of the auction
So amazingly organized, but it just sounds it's actually quite soothing to listen to them
He actually like sings a song it's so methodical iterally
Just go fish after fish we spending a few seconds bird fish and just go down the line auctioning off all of the tuna
I
Guess so really quickly just to explain the tuna are auctioned and there are buyers
So they buy the tuna and then they bring it back to the fish market
Where they cut it and where they distribute it and sell it and then sushi chefs
They they go they have their own vendor that they
I'm sure they go to they're loyal to their vendor and
So the best sushi chefs have their own vendor who is one of the best buyers because they buy the best quality of tuna
And so that's just that's just a really really quick
brief overview of a little bit of how the system works
Unfortunately, I had to give up the hat and the vest, but we are back at the tuna king
All right, and this is also known as the tuna king women king they buy the best units in the world
These are the highest quality tuna in the entire world and
This is the part
I'm really looking forward to actually is when they're gonna start cutting the tuna and the tuna are straight from the auction
I'm just overwhelmed right now. It's so fascinating you're watching this he cuts up that to an end there there
So they know it's the exact move
They need to make they cut off the fins they cut off the head they cut off various bones
But they know it's so precise they know exactly what they're doing and there's there's no room for error
And as he's slicing up that tree no we got another another shipment was delivered look at the size of this
It's huge
142 kilos
Oh, Oh that is the purest sashimi you will ever have in your life
Right out of the carcass
Oh
That was just incredible to watch them slicing up those slabs of tuna they there's no room for error
They make slices
They can only make it or just one cut and just they literally cut that tuna like it's butter just straight through it
It's just such an incredible art and those guys are the best in the world
For anything very didn't going to have
a person
I don't got the goods endeth
This is possibly the greatest treat
You could ever have it's slimy and still kind of squirming around and all man. It does not get fresher than this
One bite
All the fur it's sweet and firm you can taste the salt water college all the sweetness keeps on coming
We trick
Chef's just killed me another shrimp, and this is our boat on trip. Oh
That shrimp literally almost has the sticky texture of peanut butter oh, but with like a a
sweet
Natural almost nutty taste to it
amazing
Hey don't talk New York today's number one
This one know what it was what it was
We have only John, thank you, oh, we're now at the best unni dealer
That's cutie market, and you've just given me a little taste. It's like dripping. It's juicing
That tastes like cream
It tastes like it tastes like ice cream. I had this tiny little perfect bitterness to it
balanced by a sweetness and juiciness
Old man, oh, that's insane
Yoshitaka zombie that done, here's the only King know anything
Just nothing better than snacking at the market
Chef Kudo thought those who voiced er vendor now all that is that is beautiful it's just juicing and dripping everywhere
Oh
Oh act like a mouthful of a few and that's melt in your mouth, that's juicy that's C booty
Thank you very much that was amazing that was amazing that was an
incredible behind-the-scenes look at ski Gmarket from the auction to the cutting to seeing the best the best quality tuna in the
world
What really strikes me about
Japanese culture in general is just how?
How they respect and take such incredible care of the natural products than the natural?
Natural things the fish from the fish all the way to the to the produce, and I want to say a huge
Thank you to chef hito sato-san for taking us around and also the hungry tourists for his amazing
Network and for setting it all up that was
Fascinating and I'm pretty sleepy right now. I think I'm gonna take a little nap
And tonight we have reservations at a very well-known very
Respected sushi restaurant, it's called sushi a lie
Okay, so this sushi restaurant is in Ginza, and we've just arrived it is
somewhere oh
Actually, it's in the basement of this building
Hello
This is just a little tiny sushi bar. This is amazing it and just our entire group is taking up the entire
Sushi bar there
When you dream about a sushi bar, this is the exactly like environment atmosphere that you would think of
okay, we're starting off with an eggplant and
Eggplant dish it's absolutely gorgeous with little flowers on top
It's so smoky and sold has this earthy thought at flowerless flowers okay, and the piece of tofu
Sesame I think that's like sesame to a 100
We've got some raw baby shrimp, and they peel this raw
And then he it was just amazing to watch him as he sliced them open with just absolute dedication and perfection
Both people died both. Are you bi?
That's insane
That is like
creamy sweet butter
Looper stunning as well like so clean tasting next up for gingko nuts
We're really really nice really like silky creamy
We've only had a couple pieces already, but one of the amazing things about this restaurant is just how
Incredibly clean they keep everything so he slices the fish, and then actually you have a bar counter
But then he places your piece of sushi he gives it to you straight
but he sets it on the
Higher shelf and then your lower shelf is reserved
Beautiful slab of wood reserved clear chopsticks in your napkin and your beverage
But kids kept
Incredibly clean next step is bonito
All the freshness of that
It's just shining oh
It has like a slight
Sweet almost bloody freshness to it so awesomely good
Yeah, this is a type of clam and a huge nugget of clam what she hands it to you to eat and you can
You can actually unreal the vibrant aroma of that clam before even though they gonna bite
Okay
Yeah, that's incredibly like stry and bouncy
And it's so like muscular
Okay next up we have a little piece of fish, which has been steamed in sake and this is a little beauty of a1 butter
Melt in your mouth
Well downsweep it it you got to get a close-up look at this you see all of that Tom away that that good
Boozy like head butter with juices in there
There's the perfect combination of
crunchy head and like suckin buttery slightly bitter
like head cream oh
Your next byte is monkfish liver, and it has it has an orange color to it
Oh, that's like custard no I forgot on that one to add the wasabi I'm gonna add the whole blob of wasabi on this button
Oh
Yeah, yes, that's for sure
They just have like different purposes. Ah this is a chawanmushi
It's a type of egg custard
And there's a little dab of wasabi on the top so you can kind of mix that mix that all around
There's like some it looks all that a custard is on the bottom there, and then there's kind of like some gooey sauce
Hmm, it's so light and just dissolves it you know they're pieces of fish on the bottom as well
The sushi has begun we are starting with a piece of flounder is such an expert at making sushi
It's even hard to like keep up with the camera
Oh
The balance is just insane and also when you eat sushi
Just eating it with your fingers grabbing it right from the chef
He makes it eat it right off the table you use your fingers that just adds another element to it the next piece is
squid and
he added on a squeeze of
The citrus yuzu, I think and then a little bit of wasabi in there
I've never had raw squid like that. That's so
soft
Mmm
It has a little crunch to it, but it's so soft. It's not chewy whatsoever oh
That's citrus is amazing oh
Ma no Chuck we inject it on one okay, this one is a commie
Oh oh
That's ridiculous, oh
The fish just melts in your mouth the rice is perfectly balanced, and it's just the perfect temperature like
It's like mouth temperature the entire bite
Okay the next piece is to throw
Perfectly creamy
Perfectly salty a hint of sourness. It's literally a perfect bite
Whole
Next piece is from the like back of the tuna
And it's just glistening you just have to watch and admire him as he makes sushi literally his hands are just dancing
You don't need teeth to eat that
Well, don't ya
Buts about gold
Jews it's done a lot buddy so far everything has been exceptional
But this is one light that I've been waiting for it is the oath total the fatty tuna belly and to me it almost looks
Like like scales almost because it's so fatty that it just kind of like almost like
Starting to fall apart
For ladies
That's one of the best things you could possibly stick in your mouth it just dissolves how many rice in it oh just insane
Is your Chad okay
Let's just bite after bite of just life-changing food next up is Spanish mackerel
Although it has it like kind of gooey texture to it what I really love the flavor of
The chef at is sushi though, it's more on the salty side with a little bit of sourness
Without much, sweetness in the rice. It's absolutely perfect detail
It is in style
Just beautiful again, you can see there's tiger stripes on it
Boy next up is baby scallop
The crunch from the two weed
the scallops are just
here here
that literally has the crunch of a mushroom - it almost is his salmon roe, and he put a better price down and just a
Heap of salmon roe. This is like a little bowl of pudding you do with a spoon look that is just incredibly beautiful
They're transparent and they're actually like like light orange in color if you look at them through the light
Sometimes it takes fishy and tastes a little hot. This is like so neutral tasting
They just like burst with like slightly salty or like juice
That's my favorite type of pudding
Oh good awesome another slab of fish and rice that just melts in your mouth over and over again
Yellow
Next up for uni which is sea urchin and it's just like exploding out of the top of this piece of sushi oh
That's a dream come true in your mouth
That's like liquid liquid custard is ocean eel all it's hot
Next up is a hand roll, and he stuffed so much tuna into there
It's unbelievable if you don't need it fast enough. It will just melt on the table
this is
Perfection it's so beautiful. This is a one bite slice
That just sums up this entire experience and it's time for dessert now when you eat one
What cost a sushi like this that time? I'll go though
it's always the final bite and
Every chefs version is a little bit different. This looks. It looks really real I
Have never felt awesome place much like a sushi chef. This is awesome the chefs are amazing
Oh, yeah
Sushi now
that was
Truly a sublime meal it was
unbelievable a truly a once-in-a-lifetime
Opportunity and experience the combination of both so huge. Thank you to the hungry tourists I
Did everything with a hungry tourist on the best of Tokyo food tour?
And it's been absolutely awesome
This is these are things that would are
Almost priceless to be able to book them and to be able to arrange things like this is
I couldn't have done it without the hungry tourists. Thank you the hungry tourists
I'll leave the links in the description box you can check everything out and
Thank you very much for watching this video
Please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
And I'm gonna be publishing lots more food in travel videos so click Subscribe now
And thank you so much for watching. I'll see you on the next video